hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain
an american mystery and horror science
fiction movie called color out of space
there is a woman who is doing a ritual
by the river her name is lavinia gardner
suddenly a man comes to her ward
phillips a hydrologist who is doing a
survey in that place
feeling that the ritual is disturbed by
him she decides to go home
at home she is welcomed by her parents
named nathan gardner and theresa gardner
she also has two young brothers named
benny gardner and jack gardner
that night after they have dinner
together they do their respective
activities lavinia and jack are trying
to sleep benny is playing on the
computer accompanied by his dog while
their parents are having a good time
jack suddenly wakes up because he is
scared he comes out of the room and
later a purple light appears outside of
their house
then he immediately calls his parents
but they do not hear him he looks like
he is absorbed into the light and he
screams hysterically hearing jack scream
everyone goes to check him straight away
and they smell something strange and see
thick smoke outside
they come out of the house and search
for where the smell is coming from
finally they find a purple object which
has a strange smell and is smoky in
their yard while jack still looks
shocked in the house
the next day they call mayor tuma to
check on the strange object
unexpectedly ward comes to their house
and checks about it according to him it
is a meteorite that is not dangerous
later ward asks the family for help to
drive him to someone who also lives in
the area
then he takes ward to the person named
ezra
ward sees something strange in the drink
as a result he asks ezra for his water
to be used as research material later
at night it rains with thunder oddly the
lightning is purple it then strikes the
meteorite which fell in lavinia's yard
as she is enjoying the rain
not long after her father tells her to
come into the house
the strangeness of the place begins to
appear when ward is researching the
water that ezra has given him and then
he receives a call but the voice is not
very clear
he also sees a purple light behind the
bushes and suddenly his car starts by
itself
the next morning nathan and his wife see
that the meteorite is gone from their
yard they are grateful about it but on
the other hand they do not realize that
the meteorite has merged with the ground
and polluted the water in that place the
impact of the meteorite starts showing
when theresa is chopping carrots that
time she absentmindedly cuts off two of
her fingers therefore nathan takes her
to the hospital the children are at home
without parents and all of the
responsibility for the house is left to
benny the next morning benny takes care
of his father's alpaca while lavinia
enjoys the morning by drinking a cup of
coffee
she sees jack alone sitting in the yard
and later she approaches her little
brother she is confused about what her
brother is doing he says that he is
talking to someone who is at the well in
their yard although lavinia doesn't see
anyone there when she enters the house
jack goes to the well and then a
grasshopper comes out of the well out of
nowhere but strangely the grasshopper is
purple and its face looks very scary
long story short nathan and his wife are
on the way home from the hospital on the
way they almost hit a strange animal
luckily they make it home safely at that
time jack is waiting outside the house
alone
then nathan scolds benny in lavinia
because they couldn't take care of their
brother properly lavinia tells her
father that this place is starting to
get weird but he still doesn't care
about his children's words
later nathan becomes frustrated after
finding that his most recent harvest of
fruits has proven inedible he doesn't
notice that the leaves and insects there
have changed color to purple teresa
snaps after losing a work client due to
the faltering internet connection
bringing the two to a fight nathan's
hands turn wrinkled maybe this is one of
the consequences of the polluted water
their television also starts to not get
signals the same night lavinia tries to
perform a ritual using the necronomicon
and offering her blood to save her
family mutilating herself in the process
benny and jack go to the alpaca stables
they find that the alpacas have turned
into a scary strange beast a bolt of
color starts appearing making them run
away from the stable their mother rushes
to jack and hugs him but suddenly the
purple bolt strikes them nathan and jack
are shocked including lavinia when she
sees her mother's body and jack is fused
together nathan wants to take them to
the hospital but he is enraged because
the car is unable to start as well as
all the electronic devices
soon board wants to come back to
lavinia's home because his friend has
found the animal in that area looking
like it's been burned by radiation
later lavinia and benny want to escape
from that place they want to run away
with their horses but unfortunately
their horses can't be controlled by them
and run away instead
meanwhile benny hears his dog in the
well
he decides to go into the well to look
for his dog
abruptly the purple light reignites from
within and absorbs him he vanishes
instantly and lavinia is sad about it
suddenly her father forces her into the
house he then locks his daughter in the
room where his wife and jack are to
serve as their food
shortly after ward and his friend come
to the house he is shocked when he sees
nathan's face as turned weird
then he hears lavinia's scream and
rushes to her immediately when he get to
the room he is shocked to see teresa has
turned into a terrible monster
swiftly nathan shoots his own wife to
death
after rushing outside nathan attempts to
shoot the color emerging from the well
but ward's friend mistakes nathan's aim
and fatally shoots him
ward and his friend go to ezra's house
to check on ezra's condition
arriving there they find that ezra has
turned into a monster they decide to
leave the house but sadly his friend is
caught by the mutated tree branches
above them ward runs as hard as he can
to avoid the light then he finds lavinia
near the well and it turns out that she
also has turned into a monster
even her body has been contaminated with
the strange light there's a whirlwind
near her and it absorbs her body
entirely a frightened ward runs into the
house but instead he meets nathan who is
still alive
even though he has been shot dead
somehow he comes back alive
ward hides in the wine cellar as the
colors distortion of reality drives the
property to destruction leaving him the
only survivor as he climbs out of the
remains of the farmland now a colorless
ashy blasted heath
in the epilogue a traumatized ward
stands on top of the finish dam which
covers the former property subscribe to
watch more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching